so hello everyone I'm Brian man I am the
creator of Cyprus and today we're gonna
be talking a little bit about testing
the way that it should be now for me
Cyprus has consumed every aspect of my
life for nearly two-and-a-half years now
but you've likely never even heard of it
so in that case your first question
might be what is Cyprus
well Cyprus is a testing tool that's
written entirely in JavaScript that
helps developers like you write
automated tests for the web it's the
type of testing tool that drives a
browser like a real user would and it's
most often compared to selenium although
it is substantially different than
selenium now Cyprus is an incredibly
visual tool and I've found for all of us
to get on the same page it's easiest to
just show it in action so let's go
through a quick sixty second demo so
here we are in the Cypress desktop app
booting our project we've launched
Chrome and we're now testing apples main
navigation well now searching through
apples support system applying some
filters clicking through a help document
and finally testing it in responsive
mode with Trello we're now logging in we
are creating a new board we're adding a
story adding a comment and applying a
label now we're logging in again
we're clicking through the Trello
settings and lastly we're now testing
trelles homepage and modifying the view
the viewport to be responsive and with
Cypress we can walk back in time through
our commands so as we hover on the
command Cypress root stores Dom to the
state that it was in at that time we
display key indicators like highlighting
the elements in question or even
providing the exact hitbox where an
action such a such as a click took place
and we can also pin these snapshots
allowing this to manually inspect the
Dom or potentially cycle through
multiple snapshots such as before and
after an action took place all right now
the cynic in you may be wondering what
is the world really need another testing
tool and to answer that let me first
share my own experiences with testing so
I've been building web apps for the last
nine years and in that time I've gotten
a chance to lead development team
and often teach developers how to test
their applications but whenever our team
would invest significant resources into
writing integration and end tests would
always inevitably run into major
problems often times giving up writing
those tests altogether and after seeing
this fail over and over again for years
it ultimately led me to conclude that
testing is just too hard I mean really
lit let's be honest the tools that we
use were originally invented in 2004 so
we've had 12 years since then but it
still takes a dedicated staff of QA
engineers to do well so when I decided
to set out and try to fix this problem
in the early days of Cypress experiments
I really just focus on what I wanted to
improve for my own team but what I was
missing was external validation that
this was really a problem for developers
everywhere and for instance I wanted to
know do other developers really feel the
same kind of pain and while I was
experimenting with the first few
prototypes of Cypress I got a
recommendation to read this book and I
cannot express how valuable it was to
the early days of development and lean
startup does all that it can to prevent
you from building a product that nobody
wants that to build something that the
world really needs you must constantly
run experiments and validate your ideas
with real users in other words you have
to get out of the building and although
I new testing as a technical practice I
had no idea what other users were facing
and more importantly what they thought
the barriers were so I took to the Lean
Startup philosophy and attempted to
validate my assumptions and I asked the
world of developers what are the biggest
testing challenges that you want solving
and the world responded developers
poured in from all companies sizes and
countries tell me their struggles with
testing and the validation was obvious
developers all over the world
resonate with the same fundamental
frustrations as I do and since those
early days we have received thousands
upon thousands of these snippets but as
I'm sure you know developers complain a
lot so I still wanted to understand them
better armed with this data I started to
organize them into distinct categories
and what I found was that
our three recurring themes that
developers find challenging over and
over again and they can be organized
into the following first one is set up
so every project and every developer has
to initially set something up to start
testing this is the first barrier this
is the first barrier and it's a large
one so developers struggle to even begin
testing and thus the very first taste
they get is a bitter one the second is
writing so every project and every
developer must of course write tests but
what we find here is the developers want
an API that is much easier to write that
performs much faster and helps them
figure out what in the world just
happened when things don't go as planned
number three management so developers
struggle to even understand why a test
failed right we invested resources into
preventing regressions so when we see
tests fail we need a clear and direct
way of understanding why but what we
find here is really the opposite you've
written the tests but they oftentimes
don't help you debug a problem so why is
this the case
well the main tool that underpins nearly
all of this feedback is of course
selenium perhaps you've heard selenium
or you've heard of webdriver and you've
likely used a testing tool built on top
of selenium such as protractor webdriver
IO Nightwatch capybara or countless
others
well selenium first came around in 2004
as selenium RC and then morphed into
webdriver which has now been adopted as
the official specification so slam
clearly isn't new it's fully baked and
yet
wire developers clearly struggling to
use it well web has dramatically evolved
since the early days and I'm sure you
all know that right back in the day it
was common for all the applications to
be simple and stateless you click the
button and you've got a full page
refresh you submitted a form you got
another full page refresh you know Ajax
wasn't even really a thing does anyone
remember dotnet web forms oh those were
the days but and the JavaScript code
that we did right wasn't for building
the application itself it was only for
decorating it with some fancy form
validation or teasing animations and
more importantly the code that we did
write was mostly synchronous that is
when events would trigger like click key
down focus in Mouse over we would
respond to those events sync
and update the Dom synchronously and for
these types of applications
selenium worked great when it was all
very simple but nowadays everything and
I literally mean everything is
asynchronous there are no guarantees
when anything is ever done and because
of this it just wreaks havoc on the way
that the selenium webdriver API works
these days most of our application state
is kept in the browser and it changes
over a period of time so gone are the
days of full page refreshes so that
brings me to the most fundamental flaw
in the way that webdriver works web
drivers architecture is a stateless HTTP
API and quite simply it is literally
impossible to use a stateless API to
test a stateful system like this is a
computer science problem and no matter
how many backflips you do there's really
no way to fix it when you're issuing
webdriver commands think of it as
issuing remote commands into a black box
or picture this it's like shooting at a
firework into the night sky imagine it's
pitch black outside you cannot see
anything and then boom the firework goes
off and for a moment you see all the
shapes and figures the state of the
world but then it's gone again and no
matter how many fireworks that you shoot
into the sky you will never know the
truth you will only see one tiny
snapshot one moment in time and this is
why tests and selenium are flaky it
cannot predict nor respond to changes in
your application it can only ask a
simple question what does your state
look like at this arbitrary moment
another problem is control so
traditionally with end-to-end tests you
have no real control over things like
you do in a unit test for instance the
browser does what it does and when you
go to login or request data for a page
your server really has to respond with
that data and that means that data
really has to be in the database
you can't mock or stub things which
means that you're constantly having to
act like a real user and will guess what
in theory this makes sense but in
practice getting a robot to mimic how a
human behaves is perilously difficult
robots aren't real users robots have no
intuition and they're really stupid the
last problem is just speed oh my god
selenium is so freaking slow it's
prohibitively slow in the sense that
there's no
you could ever TDD a feature as it's
being built you're basically forced to
write tests after the fact once you've
built everything in place okay so given
these challenges hypothetically you can
muster your way through them but just
wait because it's about to get a lot
worse so for instance chroma is
automated by chromedriver which uses the
debugger protocol and the debugger
protocol is the same protocol that your
dev tools uses to provide you feedback
on everything that's happening on your
page network requests javascript console
output errors the debugger CSS style
elements etc and guess what that means
that when Chrome driver is automating
your browser you cannot have dev tools
open I mean what are you serious like
when I'm building a web app I literally
never even close dev tools
it's the lifeline for anyone working on
the web so how can you really right run
and debug tests without access to the
dev tools like how did this ever work at
any rate so try to open dev tools while
your tests are running and you'll be
faced with this message can't do it it
will fail the test and you will want to
rage quit testing altogether all right
so lastly when your tests do fail as
they will all the time you're basically
forced to debug went went what went
wrong with a stack trace now it blows my
mind to think that this is actually
helpful browsers are enormous ly
complicated pieces of software and
naturally because web applications are
stateful they change over a period of
time so when tests do fail you're
reduced to a stack trace and a terminal
but how does this help us see insight
into what the root cause was I mean
perhaps something happened several
commands before this one perhaps a
network request failed or maybe
something just took a bit longer than
you expected I mean it's tough it's
really really tough and so at the end of
the day you might be feeling a bit like
this that I hate testing but just keep
in mind this is an incredibly difficult
problem to solve and there are those of
us who are working to make the entire
process better and I for one believe
that it can be done and that there are
reasonable solutions to these problems
so my first epiphany to kind of fix the
testing ecosystem was to simply ditch
selenium all together and rebuild the
architecture from the ground up
to really work for testing modern
applications so let's take a look at
some of the key differences of how
cyprus addresses that developers biggest
concerns with testing
so remember developers say that they
struggle just to get their initial
testing harness together developers feel
that they spend too long picking the
right tools getting them to work
together and dealing with all the
configuration so one of our girl aw one
of our goals are early on was to create
a simple streamlined onboarding process
that enabled developers to write their
first passing test in under five minutes
in other words see success right out of
the gate without having to configure or
install anything other than Cypress
itself so we try to make this process as
easy as possible so here we're
installing the cypress CLI tool from NPM
and now are installing Cypress itself
once that's done we write cypress open
and now we're inside of the desktop
application to get your project set up
we just add it to Cypress and click on
the road to boot the Cypress server now
Cypress will automatically detect that
this is a new project it will seed your
project with a support directory and
example fix your file and an example
spec file from our kitchen sink app so
when we click the spec file Cypress then
launches chrome it begins running the
tests so our kitchen sink app simply
runs through every single Cypress
command so you can just see it in action
without writing a single line of code so
there it is okay so once you're set up
the vast majority of your time naturally
is spent writing new tests so this is
the area that we have focused on the
most we still have much more to do but
we'll highlight some of the biggest and
most important features that exist today
the first thing you'll notice is that as
Cypress runs its commands you receive
visual feedback for each individual
command you issue to Cypress and as
commands are being processed they'll
look like they're visually pending and
Cypress also logs out other important
page events such as when xhr requests
are made or when the page loads when the
URL is changed when a form is submitted
or when an assertion is made so without
even looking at any code you can likely
understand what is happening here now
naturally as you're writing tests you're
likely spending a lot of your time in
read dealing with a failing test so
another core goal of ours is to make
errors obvious and clear in fact we've
written no joke hundreds of custom
errors so errors are oftentimes dead
ends in software which leads to a lot of
developer frustration so we try to make
it easy for you to not only understand
why something failed but understand the
root cause in the situation of complex
error messages we oftentimes provide an
external link which provides a clearer
explanation of why ciphers error adhere
so usually these documents offer
potential workarounds or suggest
different approaches so every cypress
command also has this really nifty
feature that we call snapshotting so
this is where we take a snapshot of the
Dom when the command executed so when
you click on a command in the UI a
couple things happen we pin the snapshot
which enables you to inspect the state
of your application but we also output
helpful debugging information related to
the command in your dev tools console so
in this case we have logged the output
for the find command you can see the
selector we used which was hash tag name
the element that this was applied to
which which was the element yielded from
our previous command and then the new
Dom element that this find command
returned in this case one element was
returned but had there been zero or more
than one we would visually indicate that
to you on the command itself you'll also
notice that our application looks really
small right here
this is something Cypress does it
automatically scales the application
application isn't aware of this but
basically it completely insulates you
from different resolutions and different
screen sizes it will always act the same
no matter where it runs so that's why
dev tools are open and it looks really
small ok so here's another example of
some useful debugging information in
this case we clicked on the side op type
command and we are nice people and we
like to do nice things for you like
provide a key events table of every
single event that was fired during this
type so we capture data such as the
character code whether the key down key
press text input input or key or key up
event was fired so this is especially
helpful because it can provide insight
into what your application did for
instance when we typed enter which is
character code 13 which I'm sure many of
you know the key down event was
prevented default because react to did
that internally in this
n-b-c example alright so let's move away
from the UI components of Cyprus and
into the API or the DSL that you would
code to drive the browser Cypress is
built on top of mocha chai and sign-on
in addition to that we've replicated
api's that you're likely already
familiar with such as Jacob right we've
implemented the entire sizzle engine
which enables you to query for elements
using any kind of CSS selector the same
way that you would do it in jQuery we
use a fluent style API to where all the
commands chain off of each other it's
important to note that every command is
asynchronous so it returns a promise
under the hood now one of the more
innovative aspects of Cypress is how it
handles assertions and this is what
makes ciphers so resilient to test Flake
so in Cyprus you simply add assertions
that describe the state that you want
your application to be in and Cyprus
will automatically block and retry until
your application matches that state so
in this example on line four we're query
rating for an element with an ID of box
right and then we're adding multiple
assertions to it we're saying that it
should have the class animate it should
contain the text content after
transition and it should have a width of
100 pixels and a height of 400 pixels
and as you might be able to guess this
is actually testing an animation and a
JavaScript set timeout so let's watch
Cyprus run this test if you look closely
you can kind of even visually see and
kind of predict how Cyprus works under
the hood it knows that the element that
we're sorting on is that box div it
knows that we've added four assertions
so it actually does not resolve until
all of them associated to that element
pass though our application code is not
only using a random set timeout to
change the text but it's also using CSS
animations and but regardless Cyprus you
know handles this just fine so normally
when you attempt to interact with
elements like when clicking Cyprus will
run a series of tests on that element to
ensure that the element would be
accessible to a real user for instance
it will automatically ensure that the
element isn't being covered by another
element and it will wait until it's no
longer being covered it will ensure that
the element is visible and if not it'll
wait until it is or tell you the exact
reason why it thought it wasn't visible
but also make sure the element isn't
disabled they'll wait for it to become
enabled or
timeout and tell you that the element
never became enabled and lastly it will
also wait for an element to stop
animating and for the most part these
situations work like a charm
but cypher still offers you the
developer a way to opt out of these
kinds of checks and to force events to
happen even if it's not technically
possible so that means that you can
avoid having to act like a real user for
instance if you if you have a CSS style
on a button that displays it only when
your mouse is hovering over it well
that's kind of a pain to test for and
instead you may just wish to force the
click event to happen regardless of
whether or not the element is hidden and
for these situations and many others
this is often times just the least path
of resistance so you simply tell snipers
to force this event to happen easy so
force true acts like an escape hatch it
also comes in handy when there's
something in Cyprus that we didn't
consider like this example here so
here's one of our early adopters was
attempting to click the white anchor
text here and Cyprus was erroring out
complaining that it thought this anchor
text was being that they're trying to
click was being covered by its parent
which is a TD cell right now you can see
in this picture that's not the case like
the text is clearly visible but what's
happened here is that when Cyprus
interacts with an element by default it
fires the event at the exact center
coordinates although you can change this
in this situation the exact center just
happened to be right smack in between
the text in fact if it was a single
pixel higher it would have clipped a
text and it would have worked just fine
and so this is what I mean about robots
being really stupid and having no
intuition right a real user if you just
told them to click this they would
likely know to just kind of move their
mouse over it enough to hit the text or
when they see the little cursor pointer
appear in the browser right and really
in webdriver this would actually be a
much bigger problem but in Cyprus this
is a perfect example where you just
force true the click event and then just
move on with your test right and by the
way like the reason that this is
happening is actually completely
legitimate in this case the anchor had a
display inline style attached to it and
in that situation the element does not
displace the space between
it's text so literally if you were to
put your mouse on that exact coordinate
where we calculated the quick the click
should happen it would miss the element
and so that's why ciphers kept thinking
of being covered because when we
calculate the element at that
coordinates we were returned the TD and
not the expected anchor but welcome to a
day in the life of building tools for
browsers all right
so continuing on with this concept due
to the fundamental architectural
differences of Cyprus it's possible to
do all kinds of things that would
otherwise be impossible to do with
webdriver so in Cyprus you have native
access to everything your spec code
executes in the exact same run loop as
your application code so that means that
you can just throw down debuggers and
they work the same way as in your
application code in fact due to this
level of control you can start to think
about writing Cypress tests not as true
and end tests more like a hybrid
combination of both unit and integration
tests so like in this example we can tap
into sitout visits on before load
callback and this means that you can run
arbitrary JavaScript before any of your
application code is run so this could
enable us for instance set up like a
global user object which your
application could check for or
potentially set some local storage value
right so you can just force your
application to think a current user is
logged in then what we're going for here
is total and absolute control of your
app you no longer have to act like a
user just act like a developer and
create the state that you desire in your
application and test just that so here's
another example so imagine you have a
method on your app object called login
now normally your login method might do
some crazy oauth logic like opening up
some facebook window which is
problematic because that relies on
another service and their UI but in this
example just you would just do what
you'd normally do in a unit test right
you'd stub out this function and just
force it to give what you want and this
way we bypass facebook altogether so one
oh if you want to write a test that
simulates what happens when Facebook
fails well it'd be easy to just make
that happen
so speaking of control in Cypress you
could also do things like xhr stubbing
so instead of seeding your database and
dealing with setup and teardown it's
oftentimes just much easier to just
force your server to
respond with the data that you care
about and this is all baked first class
into Cypress and there's just so much
power at your fingertips to do this so
in this example we are saying that when
a post request matches the the URL
proposals to respond with a 500 status
and no response body and in Cyprus we
enable you to reference the
relationships between multiple commands
so on line 16 were actually telling
Cyprus to wait for an F for an xhr
request that matched the route that we
define above so for instance if an xhr
didn't go out instead of receiving an
error about like a missing Dom element
and wondering what the root cause of
that was you would instead receive an
error about the true cause of the
problem that an xhr that you expected to
be sent was never actually sent out so
you can have a much tighter contract
between your test code in the
application code and in fact it we can
wait on xhrs
even if we don't stub them which is
another excellent strategy to guard
Cyprus and block its command execution
until the desired state of your
application has been reached so why are
we stubbing the service response in the
first place well simple our application
is built to toss up a error modal
whenever the xhr fails so here's that
application in action right so notice
that the modal appears briefly because
as part of this test we basically
dismiss at the moment that it appears if
you look closely you can see that our
command GUI displays these relationships
between commands we have a routing table
which includes a list of everything that
you've stubbed and then when exit chars
are made from your app we list them out
so and if they match an alias that
you've defined we like visually indicate
that to you like highlighted in yellow
so hopefully these examples give you a
brief overview of some of the ways in
which writing tests in Cyprus is very
different than any other tool out there
all right so onto part 3 management so
in my position in my opinion this is
actually the hardest part to really
solve well and so what what exactly do I
mean by test management well so as you
and your teammates write tests they grow
and accumulate old tests go in a
maintenance mode and naturally whenever
you check a new code all the tests run
NCI and here is where we find ourselves
needing a lot more help than what we
have today and for instance one of my
friends Sam ciccone who
at Google he tweeted this one day that
perfectly sums up managing test and CI
he says that every time ID bug CI the
less I understand how we can possibly
land and operate Rovers on other planets
I love this tweet but one of the
responses was even better so Fabien
replied well I don't think those Rovers
are running JavaScript which you know
it's probably true probably true all
right so it's Cyprus nearly half of our
team has spent this entire year focused
on this problem and here is how we think
that we can solve it the currently
Cyprus is built on top of electron and
we've jumped through an enormous amount
of Hoops to make it perform nearly
identically to Chrome except with
electron you have the ability to run
headless Lee so when you go to run your
tests in CI they'll run in this headless
mode but that of course introduces like
a crucial problem right if your tests
are running headless Lee how the heck do
you see what happened when they failed
and how do you get insight into that
well the way that we're solving this is
basically by building a service around
CI runs so when a run finishes we pull
off all the build assets and host them
in our cloud platform once we process
them the results are then piped directly
back into the desktop app so for
instance given that we have these
projects set up in Cyprus after we run
our tests and CI the results from those
tests will be made available in the
desktop app and each individual project
will also have a list of builds and this
serves two primary purposes the first is
that we'll automatically collect all the
build data for a run and give you the
ability to access to this data
externally similar to the way that sauce
labs or browser stack works let me be
clear we're not a CI provider nor are we
even a competitor of sauce or browser
stack we essentially sit right in the
middle between all of them and we'll
work perfectly well so from here you can
now access this build data and because
we're integrated as such a fundamentally
lower level than say webdriver it means
that cyphers is capable of understanding
everything that happened in the browser
so initially you know we'll be providing
things that you'd expect like the
individual errors a running video of the
whole build screenshots and all the logs
from everything that happened under the
hood and later I see us doing other
things like memory or performance
regression testing arguably more
importantly we'll probably do things
like visual regression
testing which is screenshot diffing
right the last thing I just want to
mention here is that even this in my
opinion isn't enough right so getting
access to the facts after they've
happened and getting insight into your
run is of course extremely important but
so kind of misses what we really need as
developers to debug failures in CI so
for instance if you're experiencing a
failure in CI even if you can clearly
see in a video or in a screenshot you
still have to reproduce it locally so
that you can iterate on the root cause
and really that's where I believe CI can
only truly be solved so as part of our
CI platform we'll be offering you as a
way to automatically connect and watch
your CI runs in real time but what's
more important is that you'll be able to
interact with this with the CI run
exactly as if it's running on your
machine so you'll have your standard
browser open you'll see all of your
cypress commands just like the browser
was running locally and you'll be able
to remotely interact with that other
browser that means that we can do things
like automatically synchronize your app
and test code with the remote cypress
instance so that when a failure occurs
you can drive into it you can modify
your code locally and see the results in
real time all while really running in
your CI instance which is where the
problem is happening now beyond just
features though I want to share a few
goals that were focused on and that are
really personally important to me for us
to get right and what we're trying to
build will really only be possible with
the adoption in the endorsement of the
open source community at large right
we're not trying to build an enterprise
ERP system or make something that's used
at like offshore QA companies right and
naturally we want to be good open-source
citizens and that means having Cypress
be completely open-source and managing
our repos and community engagement like
professionals so I mean we really want
to be champions of a testing process
that really works for developers right
we want a clear path to success and not
be afraid to be opinionated about it and
as part of a clear path to success
I hold our documentation up to the
highest standards so we've already
written several hundred pages
documentation and I expect that trend to
continue we always try to go out of our
way to not just document how to
technically do something but to further
explain the reasoning the why you'd want
to do something in a particular way and
lastly I just want to say above all
right what we're trying to create is
developer happiness and I know that's
probably a worn out and often cliche
sounding phrase but it's true you know
we're trying to create an experience
that is good that works with the way
that we build modern applications and to
do that and to get community adoption we
want developers to feel happy using
ciphers and we want to be part of the
solution and not just another problem so
I'll close with where we're headed at
riders so we're actually a five-person
full-time team and we're completely
funded by venture capital dollars we
raised a seed round at the beginning of
this year and we'll be raising a series
a early next year so that means that we
can finally hire more awesome engineers
like yourselves to work on an awesome
project so please come talk to me which
by the way we use react on all of our
front ends including the desktop app the
Skype app or urine runner now for the
bad news so at the moment Cypress is
like halfway open source right many of
the repos that make up suckers are
public but some are not but do not worry
this is really only temporary we're
actually in a closed invite beta and
have been this way for the last year so
that means sad-faced
it start using Cypress you have to be
invited but since I know that's not what
you want to hear for today and tomorrow
we've lifted those restrictions and so
if you go and download Cypress from NPM
you can start using it today and you'll
automatically be whitelisted forever and
ever so go have fun
but that said this is not a general
public release this is just for you all
who are here today so be nice don't be
posting mean things on Hacker News we're
getting there just be a little patient
it's still very much in beta and one
last thing just remember that Cypress
isn't selenium it's not bound to the
same restrictions as different ones but
I think overall there are many positive
trade-offs you can approach testing your
application in a different way than
maybe are you used to you don't have to
act like a user
so give it a go come chat with us let us
know what you think and remember to be
nice thank you
great Thank You ginger we're gonna have
questions so we're gonna do four minutes
of questions sixty four thumbs up
awesome can seifer's run headless on a
continuous integration server yes it
takes two lines of code and your CI
script to run Cypress headless Lee it's
all it's all baked into it is it
supporting ie
um this is uh the you know one of the
big million-dollar questions right now
Cypress only supports chrome chromium
and canary and electron but everything
that we have built at Cypress is
basically down the road we're gonna
support those other browsers we have to
basically set up drivers for them and
write the automation scripts a yes or a
No yeah it doesn't right now it will
there's not gonna be anything
prohibitive that's gonna prevent us from
supporting it in the future are there
any plans about ciphers supporting for
support for react native ciphers we'll
only forever and ever
support Dom based tooling it has a Dom
it can test it mobile where they can
test not native it's impossible great
with redux time-traveling cypress has
access to everything in your application
so you would just simply hook into the
state and I mean and then you just
integrate it you just code to it so I
don't see why not
good it'd be used to test web apps on
real phone if it's mobile web yes
already played with Cypress it's awesome
pricing for projects is keeping me from
using it right now when will this info
beat this closed our initial plan is to
release and it be free for everyone we
definitely are going to eventually put
up a pay wall for private projects and
we have no idea what the pricing will be
but it's gonna be like typical you know
software as-a-service stuff not like
ridiculous or anything it's gonna be
priced accordingly it makes sense can
its source states so you don't have to
go to have to through the whole
application my journey produced your log
and every time you need to test features
at the end of this journey
absolutely so it's not quite like that
but basically you can do things in
Cyprus like you can just instead of your
UI
you can there's a command called site on
request which will automatically set and
get cookies under the hood it's not
bound to origin restrictions and you can
essentially use what Cyprus already has
to bypass having to like follow all
those steps of the UI so the answer is
you is yes
phantom j s+ castro also solves all this
problems what is the advantage of Cyprus
you can't see phantom Jas are you
kidding me it's headless you can't see
anything so with Cyprus you work in the
browser all day every day building your
app like there's no difference between
your development environment and your
test environment you just write your
code and test at the exact same time
it's impossible to do that with phantom
and Kassar so I don't know you're
energetic about his answer yeah can we
set risk with electrum it's possible
it's possible I mean your spectral
inspect Ron uses selenium it's really
good
wellspect Ron is really good but I kind
of fall back to the whole Dom thing it's
possible do this electron and with
Chrome extensions but not supported out
of the box oh there's a next question
can we test it is it is possible to do
definitely not supported right now in
the era of components and with chess
snapchat testing are the usually fragile
integrations are still as relevant
that's a that's a wonderful question I
mean I think you can absolutely make a
case for the react land of tooling that
definitely full-blown ete tests or
integration tests or definitely lower on
the meter but you know this stuff exists
but over a third of all of our early
adopters use it to test for yeah so it's
kind of like you don't have to
necessarily have full-blown end-to-end
tests and but you also have to kind of
keep in mind that react amongst the
entire web stratosphere is a tiny tiny
tiny fraction of the amount of apps out
there so so yes I know so last question
what browsers are supported and what
plans to have to extend to the entire
entirety of the currently existing
browserstack
I mean we just basically have to write
adaptors for all the different browser
drivers it's really not that difficult
it's mostly just operationally
challenging for us because as soon as we
support another browser we have to
internally run all of our tests against
that and you know our early adopters
just getting your test to work in chrome
completely like end-to-end is such an
amazingly beneficial thing like you you
have such a high degree of confidence
that really the tests all these other
browsers you're only getting like
incremental improvements you know if
everything runs in chrome you're like
ninety ninety-five percent confidence
and all you're really getting out of
doing cross browser testing is you're
just catching the tiny amounts of
differences between each browsers so I
mean we are gonna do it it's an
important question but I think
personally that cross browser testing is
on it's going down especially with all
the modern stuff there's not a lot of
differences between all the browsers
anymore awesome thank you very much
Thank You Ryan
[Applause]